welcome back well in the last
presentation i showed you that if uh if
i had the function let me make sure my
if i had the function f of x
is equal to x squared
that the derivative of this function
which is denoted by f
f look at that my pen is already
malfunctioning
the derivative of that function
is that f
prime
of x
is equal to 2x and i used the limit
definition of a derivative i used the
let me write it down here the limit
look at this pen
is hard i need to really figure out some
other tool to use
the limit
as h
approaches zero sometimes you'll see
delta x instead of h but it's the same
thing
of f
of x plus h
minus f of x
over h
and i use this definition of of a
derivative which is really just the
slope at any given point along the curve
up to figure this out that if f of x is
equal to x squared that the derivative
is 2x and you can actually use this uh
to do others and i i won't do it now
maybe i'll do it in a future
presentation but it turns out that if
you have f of x
is equal to
x to the third
that the derivative is
f prime of x
is equal to 3
x
x squared
if f of x
is equal to
x to the fourth
well then the derivative is
prime of x
is equal to
4x
to the third i think you're starting to
see a pattern here
if i actually wrote up here that f f x
let me see if i have space to write it
neatly
if i wrote f of x i hope you can see
this f of x is equal to x
well you know this i mean y equals x
what's the slope of y equals x well
that's
that's just one right
y equals x has a slope of one you didn't
know you didn't need to know calculus to
know that
right f prime of x is just equal to 1
right
and then you could probably guess what
the next one is if f of x
is equal to
x to the fifth
then the derivative is
i think you could guess
right it's 5
x to the fourth so in general for any um
for any expression i guess within a
within a polynomial or any any degree x
to whatever power let's say
f
of x
is equal to
this pen drives me nuts
f of x is equal to
x to the n right where n could be any
exponent then f
prime of x
is equal to
n
x to the n minus 1. and you see this is
what the case was in all of these
situations
that 1 didn't show up
to n minus 1 right so if n was
25 x to the 25th power the derivative
would be 25
x to the 24th so i'm going to use this
rule and then i'm going to show you a
couple of other ones and then now we can
figure out the derivative of pretty much
any polynomial function
so just another couple of
rules this might be a little intuitive
this might be intuitive for you and if
you use that limit definition of
derivative you could actually prove it
but if i have
if i wanted to figure out the derivative
of
let's say
the
the derivative of
so this is another oh i'm on the wrong
layer
so another way of the this this is kind
of what is the change with respect to x
this is another
notation i think this is what leibniz
uses to figure out kind of the
derivative operator so if i wanted to
find the derivative of
if i wanted to find the derivative of
a
f of x
right where a is just some constant
number it could be 5 times f of x this
is the same thing as saying a
times the derivative
of f x
and what does that tell us well this
tells us that let's say i had f of x
of x is equal to
and this only works with constants f of
x is equal to
x squared
right
well this is the same thing as
5 times
x squared i i know i'm saying the
obvious so we can just say that the
derivative of this is just 5 times the
derivative of x squared so f prime of x
is equal to 5
times and what's the derivative of x
squared right it's 2x
so it equals 10x
right similarly if i had let's say i had
g of x i'm just using a different letter
g of x
is equal to and my pen keeps
malfunctioning g of x is equal to
let's say
x to the 12th
then g prime of x
or the derivative of g
is equal to 3 times
the derivative of x to the 12th well we
know what that is that's 12
x to the 11th
which you would have seen if 12x to the
11th
and this equals 36
x to the 11th pretty straightforward
right you just multiply the constant
times whatever the derivative would have
been i think you you get that
now one one other thing if i had
if i wanted to apply the derivative
operator
let me change colors just to mix things
up a little bit let's say if i wanted to
apply the derivative operator
i think this is called the addition rule
it might be a little bit obvious
f of x
plus
plus g of x
this is the same thing as the derivative
of f of x
plus
the derivative
of g of x that might seem a little
complicated to you but all it's saying
is that you can find the derivative of
each of the parts when you're adding up
and then that's the derivative of the
whole thing
i'll do a couple of examples
so what does this tell us and then this
is also the same thing of course this is
this is i believe leibniz's notation and
then lagrange's notation is
and of course these were kind of the
founding fathers of calculus
that's the same thing as f prime of x
plus g prime of x
and let me apply this because whenever
you apply it i think it starts to seem a
lot more obvious so let's say i want
let's say f of x
is equal to
x squared plus
x
plus 3.
well if we just want to figure out the
derivative we just say f prime of x
we just find the derivative of each of
these terms well this is 3 times the
derivative of x squared the derivative
of x squared we already figure out is 2x
right so this becomes 6x really you just
take the 2 multiplied by the 3 and then
decrement the 2 by 1. so it's it's
really 6x to the first which is the same
thing as 6x plus
the derivative of 5x is 5 and you know
that because if i just had a line that's
y equals 5x the slope is 5 right
plus and what's the derivative of a
constant function what's the derivative
of 3 well
i'll give you a hint graph y equals 3
and tell me what the slope is
right the derivative of a constant is 0.
and you can well i'll show
other times why that might be more
intuitive but plus 0. so you could just
ignore that it's f prime of x is equal
to 6x plus 5. let's do some more
i think the more examples we do the
better
let's say
i want to keep switching notation so you
don't so that you don't get daunted
whenever you see it in a different way
let's say y
equals
x to the fifth
minus
x to the third
plus
x plus 1.
so here we're going to apply the
derivative operator so we say
say d y
this is lagrange i think leibniz's
notation d y over dx
right and that's kind of the change in y
over the change in x over very small
changes right that's what kind of how i
view this d it's like a very small delta
is equal to 5 times 10 is
x to the fourth
minus
21 right 3 times 7
x squared
plus four
and then the one is the derivative one
is just zero so there we did we figure
out the derivative of this very
complicated function and it was pretty
straightforward i think you'll find that
uh derivatives of polynomials are
actually more straightforward than a lot
of concepts that you learned a lot
earlier in mathematics
that's all the time i have now for this
presentation in the next couple i'll
just do a bunch of more examples and
i'll show you some more rules for
solving even more complicated
derivatives see in the next presentation